Jacob has three real deformed feet I
mean three real deformed toes I'm high
hold
on I'm not some freak Show all right
hold on I had an accident when I was uh
when I was 18 and I got my uh my three
toes stuck in a truck lift they look
real up I've been trying to talk
him into doing an only fans for a
street and we would call it Tony fans
and but we would dress his feet up like
famous people people like like athletes
like one of his toes would be Like toell
Beckham
Jr tow burrow you know and we dress them
all up toe Biden we do the whole thing
but he said I he didn't want to do it I
was like you're going to make some real
money if we dress up your feet hold on
real quick Shaquille toel are you
kidding me right now maybe I'll get
influen Round of Applause for people who
would subscribe to that
page